have you talked to Elon about this about
this game over there a little bit how
much of reality like the work of SpaceX
is an inspiration for the decisions made
in this game
I wouldn't say it's for the decisions we
made but
you know visiting SpaceX and walking in
there it was
it's like the Avengers Mitch NASA it's
like the most amazing and here we're
building the next gen like see the the
dragon stuff before it was uh you know
other people saw it like just I was
really
in awe
you know this giant machine that looks
for imperfections on the surface of
these giant
you know
fuselah just you know whenever and
because you know we're in DC go to the
air and space museum a lot and so
whenever I look at those kind of things
or you know you'll visit the space
shuttle sort of overcome with how big it
is and I go stand back by the engines
and think about that thing leaving orbit
you know and one of the things that Elon
really impresses like we're reaching the
edge of physics on a lot of this stuff
where how hard it is
to leave
orbit
the gravitational pull and like so the
engineering that has gone into that our
space program what what he's doing now
um I just marvel at I don't understand
oh right I'm not at that level but I
Marvel at the kind of human Ingenuity
and scale
I was
on the Delaware Coast last month
and I went I was outside I was outside
for some reason it was dark and I saw
this crazy light in the sky
and I thought it was like a helicopter
and then it didn't go away and like if
someone what is that I called my we had
with some friends hey does everybody see
this what is that and we just stood
dumbfounded looking at this thing in the
sky
and
like that is a UFO nobody takes their
phone out everyone I'm with like four
people everyone is too dumbstruck you
would think why don't you take a picture
of this thing
and the next day we found out it was in
the news it was the SpaceX launch in
Florida
and I'm seeing it from
Delaware Maryland area it was one of the
most it was incredible it's just even
just that
I am in complete of
is there some aspect to that that you
can replicate the The Majestic nature
that in in the video game
um I wish I had the answer to that you
know I think some of it we
we're doing when you're standing on a
planet and you see you see the other
moons go by yeah and then you realize I
could get my ship blast off and land
there and build myself a home I think
that's pretty cool
there's a minor thing we do which is we
um we have other ships come and go from
the Star ports when you're there so
you'll be in a city and then you hear
this you hear the engine you look up and
the ship is taking off or coming like
that's great there's nothing for you to
do but
it's I think it's awesome yeah yeah
and then that's all about creating the
soundscape to feel
seeing it and like oh that's real that's
a ship that or you jump into a system
and you see these Freighters and
sometimes they contact you like
um it's not all just like jump in and
combat
do you ever think about the fact that
science fiction seems to make a
it has a way of creating reality
not just kind of predicting it or
imagining it it's almost like the thing
you put out there with a video game like
this
like Starfield that you kind of
anticipate
it it kind of uh fuels people's
imagination what is possible
maybe I don't know I don't know I can't
I can't say you're making me think now
about other science fiction that
movie I love Minority Report it's more
of like a not a space movie but more
like looking at the future if you look
at a lot of the things in that movie
it's almost like I think those are
coming true yeah I mean uh is that the
one that you do interface this like uh
it's the interfaces and then the you
know he looks his child's more like a
holographic almost AR VR kind of thing
or digital billboards
or trying to predict human behavior
um there's that there's just a lot of
future stuff in that movie as it comes
to sci-fi to your other question I don't
know I I don't know
well I think it does and it's
interesting I mean I suppose
you're trying to create the most realist
sticking to the tone the most immersive
realistic world and almost by accident
you create the thing that is possible
because you want it to be realistic in
some deep sense so
accidentally can become the possible and
then that places that idea in people's
heads I mean if humans are ever to
become a multi-planetary species
we need
we need to play games
we need to read sci-fi to help imagine
that that's possible to look outside of
Earth to look outside look up on the
stars then we can actually travel out
there I don't know there's power to
sci-fi to do that I guess you shouldn't
feel the pressure of that
I don't know if I'd make the leap
now that's all that what we're doing
might now maybe you know
one of our you know hopefully it might
Inspire some young people who are headed
in that direction alike
Oh I thought about getting into space
and space exploration and being an
engineer doing these things and I played
this game and
you know it really
sparked that interest in me so I'm gonna
go take that as a field and maybe that's
the person who goes and does some of
these things yeah because in the next
couple of decades
a likely a human being will step foot on
Mars which are the first steps towards
us becoming multi-planetary